[Music]
in too rich to care news I want to get
their meat you want to get Dyna to be
like that yeah submitted by Joe the best
thank you very much
luxury brands including Burberry are
facing scrutiny for burning leftover
clothes instead of donating them Barry
but then it's like it feels like such a
ways to donate or give it away or
anything it's just too much stock so it
doesn't some of it is also the law to
like so some company yeah so like for
example like if you're if you're sitting
on extra fabric or whatever as a
clothing company a lot of the laws
actually state that you either have to
donate it to be a tax deductible or you
have to burn it really like like destroy
it so it's it's actually the law for
because you can't be holding all that
[ __ ] inventory dude because if it's a
tax thing yeah if that doesn't get sold
then you can't write it off so some
people don't know that and they're just
outraged you're just but what about the
homeless and so those are little give
the choices hmm damn they didn't mention
anything about the law well people don't
know like well even why they're doing it
yeah like why would a an article writer
or a journalist for some newspaper know
the exact like laws for an apparel
company but we didn't know until we got
there yeah a lot of these people don't
know unless they start a business all
the technicalities and [ __ ] others oh
dude all right
[ __ ] barb a homie so Burberry
destroyed 65 million dollars worth of
products in the past five years they're
saying that just in 2017 is 36.5 million
it destroyed more [ __ ] than I've sold in
my life in my nightstand that's crazy
man like that's kind of rough like I get
it you kind of have to like you want to
protect your brand yeah sure they're
fleeting that number two and giving you
the retail not the cost they're like if
it won't cost this and imagine all these
like so much yeah so much business terms
you know they they do this in grocery
stores I think I don't know if it's
France but it's somewhere in Europe
where if the stuff is about to go then
they they have to get the food and
donate it to a shelter or whatever but
we can't do that here in the States
because if a homeless person gets sick
then they can sue whoever donated or
give the guns and then you get me old
food I'm gonna see you yeah so they have
to just throw it away so there's a lot
of [ __ ] food waste going on depends on
them yeah I really liked hellofresh I'm
kind of sad that they all closed down
but they had like a section of about to
expire stuff and you can buy it at other
close down hello fresh you mean fresh
and easy there you go
oh yeah I want to say thanks to hell
afresh you're sponsoring this video
anyway they shut down yeah thanks who
knows yeah so in this article they are
reporting though that more than sixteen
point five tons of H&M stock was burned
last year helping to power a small
Swedish city instead of using coal oh so
there's like other ways they can be
using all this overstock that they have
but burying a lot of luxury brands they
just burn it cuz imagine if you save up
money right you save up for like years
to buy your first
Alvie purse and then you buy it and you
like you're like [ __ ] you I got this and
now a bunch of homeless people have it
not to say they don't deserve it but
it's like yeah I get it like you're
buying it for a reason there's a reason
why these brands are so expensive and
it's because of the name you're buying
it for the exclusivity and all that yeah
but even okay but even if it's not
clothing and luxury right like let's say
let's say you you paid for a board game
mm-hmm let's say you bought uh uh one of
our shady agents board game right nice
and well done right right so let's say
let's say you bought one for 35 bucks
only 35 bucks
yeah only 35 say it's the but it's over
now what it's over now but right what if
we turned around and then we had like a
hundred thousand copies in stock and we
said oh [ __ ] we have all these extra
ones we're gonna give it out for free
right yeah it's it's cool for the people
that got it for free but what about all
the other people that had to pay for it
they're like what the [ __ ] man if I just
waited I could've got it for free right
it falls homeless and just [ __ ]
sucking dick on the street I could've
got one for free yeah even
it's a little bit different because it's
35 bucks right whereas these luxury
brands it's like about hundreds and
thousands of dollars that we're talking
about yes so my point is that even at a
smaller scale it's still not fair
you don't mean like it's still like fog
that's what what about the people that
did pay for it what about the people
that did earn it right if there was the
only way I mean and that's probably so
much unnecessary effort for them though
but like a big it just like cut the
logos and [ __ ] off husband donate it you
know I'm saying but then I feel like
with you have that much product is it
just gonna cost you have to hire
somebody to do all that [ __ ] yeah well
they are saying here though too that the
shareholders are unhappy about the
amount of clothes being destroyed
because they're asking like why aren't
these products oh no not only that but
why aren't these unsold products not
offered to the company's private
investors Oh like what apparently they
don't so why can't we just get some free
[ __ ] like maybe like a discount like to
your private show shareholder so you
could still be selling it interesting I
feel like this would happen like if I
have stock in Burberry they're like hey
you get a special newsletter for for
having stock in Burberry and in there
like these are gonna be blowout burnout
sales you can get this back for
basically the price that it cost you're
investing in the company discount yeah
that all depends on the law I think wow
I like that hmm was doing that thing to
powered a little City though I mean yeah
now it's pretty tight if you got a burn
shed find find a way to make it you know
worthwhile for somebody yeah H&M had a
rough year that [ __ ] they did yeah
remember they had the little t-shirt the
low-rises shirt on accident we're on
purpose or whatever the little what was
it the craziest monkey in the jungle
some [ __ ] like that
cute ass monkey nose like a cute baby or
something that shirt you know H&M in
Europe I think is different from here
because I I put on some pants and I got
some things out in France and then I
went to
out here it was insane oh the sizes the
quality the sizes European sizes are
just smaller I think right everywhere
else in the world everything is special
yeah cuz they just same thing right
Japan all that fits perfectly in the
event I'm not an origin Asian dude I was
ro with Rick once and I was like and I
put on a sweater it fit me perfectly and
I'm like oh it's too large rigs like I
can't even buy a scarf in here it's
alright yeah yeah he's like he just knew
that it wasn't gonna work that European
sizing barn it you [ __ ] big where we
have much overstock we usually like when
we have sales or whatever we ends up
selling all of it but then if we gets to
the point where we do have a surplus the
law says we either have to give it away
to be a tax deductible you're not really
gonna build this so like let's say
something from 2015 no one wants to buy
that [ __ ] old Vogel's old designs
whatever you have to give it away as a
full donation or you have to destroy it
which usually means burn it you can't do
like a vintage sales people do that all
the time so for example sale the current
Nike met cons the the CrossFit shoes
they were the old Kobe's mmm so they
made a ton of them and then I think
they've decided not to release them so
they didn't know what to do with them
and then they just rebranded it and then
now it became the met cons but if you
put them side by side they're the exact
same thing and one of our homies I used
to work for Nike SB told us the secret
we're like it was so mind-blowing so
companies like that they're so big that
they can take a product and rotate it
every 10 years right and you'll just
never even know where it actually came
from but that's also part of their game
if their game is to get rid of something
that's tax deductible
not everyone can like always do that
like moving parts yeah especially like
something else like a luxury brand you
can't it's hard to pull the wool over
someone's eyes if you're like you pull
out 10 year-old LV and you're like this
is the new LV
cuz a lot of people collect that [ __ ]
yeah cuz it's like they know like
specific season pieces and years and
[ __ ] like this is like a 1998 fall
Burberry coat yeah I don't know so a lot
of people will make the argument that
luxury brands put a lot of like
craftsmanship and care and quality and
yes yes that's true
but a pair of sunglasses does not cost
$20,000 but the thing is exclusivity and
the art behind it and things like that
you're buying art pieces that's the
argument that they're creating but in
reality it's what whoever they cover the
convinced it's worth that and they're a
believer then that's all it is
boom take my money I mean and it works
the same way as like an art piece
woodworking I'm saying there's a bunch
of [ __ ] dope broke artists that
nobody knows about they'll probably sell
their pieces like 20 bucks but then once
you get hyped
you know Picasso could squiggle anything
on a piece of paper and it'll sell for
thousands because he's Picasso but the
crazy [ __ ] is when it's hyped it's mass
manufacture like everything else but
they still [ __ ] charge you up the end
yeah a perfect example is decent Street
where it's like supreme yes they have
like they sell bricks just with supreme
on it yeah what is that very Street
where it's a [ __ ] brick you know what
trips me the [ __ ] out when we were in
Japan when the supreme store the supreme
white t-shirt it [ __ ] they left Hanes
on there mmm and in the it's a panes
undershirt it's almost see-through but
because it says supreme this Hanes
undershirt is 80 bucks and they just let
Hanes on you can't look at these brands
like that at all though if you look at
it like that then of course it's not
worth it but it's the lifestyle that's
attached to it that people buy into and
that's what puts the price tag on it so
exactly if people believe then they will
pay for even even like talking about I
was like spent 80 bucks on this hand cuz
it means something right cuz not it it
speaks to the masses like this is this
is who I am now this is what identify
with I believe in whatever so even
street wear brands are like this is a
regular [ __ ] t-shirt like you can't
reinvent a [ __ ] t-shirt like
we're using triple-a or whatever but
then they're still selling it for like
200 bucks even when the easy [ __ ] first
dropped it was like it was on the tag
the tags would start was a regular ass
t-shirt brand and it was like but you
know easy shirts is going for like one
only about five bucks yeah a lot the
shoes everything
[Music]